planning for your future is a good thing
it's a necessary thing even even though
it's uncertain you have to remember the
sun does rise every morning yeah so just
keep moving
I just hope that all of you guys
transcend whatever you see as your
obstacles and that you live outstanding
lives and that you stay connected to
your communities because you have so
much power there and that you grow your
communities and you diversify your
communities and that you don't let
anybody
anybody tell you you can't or to be
afraid it's okay to be afraid because
you can't be brave or courageous
without fear
the idea of being courageous is that
even though you're scared you just do
the right thing anyway
my mother and my grandmother were
freaked out you know I was the first
person in my family not to go to college
that had not been a slave right so I was
really breaking from tradition and uh
it was like a graduation lunch we were
having and they had my dad come and talk
to me and my dad takes me outside and
he's like listen and this is some advice
that applies to all you acting students
he says to be an actor is a lonely life
everybody wants to make it and you might
not make it and I said to my dad well
that depends on what making it is there
it says what do you mean I said well
you're a teacher I said if I could make
a teacher salary doing comedy I think
that's better than being a teacher
and he started laughing
he said if you keep that attitude I
think you should go
he said but name your price
in the beginning
if it ever gets more expensive than the
pricey name get out of there the worst
thing to call somebody is crazy is
dismissive
I don't understand this person so
they're crazy these people are not crazy
they're strong people maybe the
environment is a little sick you have no
idea what I put this woman through if
you were just giving birth to me that
would have been more than enough with
the fact that she raised me and raised
me well he had a real oral tradition in
our house I knew the word griot when I
was a little boy agrio was a person in
Africa
who's charged with keeping the stories
of The Village everyone would tell gril
the stories and they would remember them
all so that they could tell future
Generations when they got old they'd
tell them to someone else and they say
in Africa when agrio dies it's like a
library was burnt down
and my mother used to tell me before I
ever thought about doing comments she
said you should be a Grio
and she's fill me with every story of
black life you know she's educated in
African-American studies and she would
let me understand the context that I was
being raised in that I'm being raised in
a hostile environment that I have to
tame by the time I was 14 years old I
was in nightclubs mastering in adult
worlds terrifying crack epidemic was
going on and my mother would hear
gunshots outside and be scared of death
maybe it's my son but early in my career
if you remember Mom you used to sit in a
club with me she'd do a full day of work
you'd be back there falling asleep just
waiting for me to go on she would watch
my show every night do you know how long
that car ride is home how many of you
have ever heard your mother say jokes
for a little too much tonight son
that was a soft tent
I was sensitive I cried easy and I would
be scared to fist fight and my mother
used to tell me this thing I don't even
know if you remember but you said this
to me more than once you said Son
sometimes you have to be a lion so you
can be the lamb you really are I talked
this like a lion
I'm not afraid of any of you when it
comes word to word I will gab with the
best of them just so I can chill and be
me and that's why I love my art form
because I understand every practitioner
of it whether I agree with them or not I
know where they're coming from they want
to be heard they got something to say
there's something they notice they just
want to be understood
love this genre it saved my life it's
okay to be afraid because you can't be
brave or courageous
without fear the idea of being
courageous is that even though you're
scared you just do the right thing
anyway
you know it was funny I was talking to a
guy he basically said to me that comedy
is a Reconciliation of paradox
and I think that that was a
irreconcilable moment for me that I was
in this very successful place but the
emotional content of it didn't feel
anything like what I imagined success
should feel like just didn't feel right
Fame is a horrifying concept when it's
aimed at you you know at the end of the
day you don't have that much control of
it you just try to conduct yourself as
best you can
this guy named JT news he said
you know folks everybody starts
somewhere tonight this young man is
still stand up comedy for the first time
he goes and who knows we may be
witnessing the birth of a star please
welcome Dave Chappell
that was it I've been pretty good ice
cream and it's like that's all for you
kid that's all for you but they were
treated like you know like I was in the
Make-A-Wish Foundation or something they
just wanted to give me a little boost
but it was encouraging man and and it
felt so good you know you'll go through
a million bad nights comedy's weird the
line moves it changes but I think a lot
of especially in comedy a lot of it has
to do with intent to make people laugh
to reconcile Paradox I'm like just
openly sometimes I'm just openly been I
think that when you get to a certain
altitude
there's more scrutiny over the things
you say because the platform is so
powerful
I go to a comedy club and check it out
Live Comedy is the most incredible thing
in the world to me like the first time
you see a dude just standing there
talking
every joke he's saying just hitting is
working
every weekend I would go I get a little
money and to the point they started
knowing me I just sit in the crown I
just be watching and then on Tuesdays
they had an open mic and I go on Tuesday
to see why people won't work weekends
were to see why people were working
Tuesday I was figuring out
what's wrong with these people
to watch a comedian bomb is is one of
the greatest things in the world I love
it
and then at that point I was talking to
a comedian after one of the shows and uh
and the owner of the comedy club and
they were both saying you know if you
want to be a good comedian you gotta
take acting classes
and they didn't explain it
but after that I went home and I said
Mom I gotta take acting place
I had never bombed let alone got good
off stage and bombing was horrifying
nobody wants to bomb people say you do
comedy what happens if nobody laughs I
don't know
so that night was liberating because I
failed so far beyond my wildest
nightmares of failing that it was like
hey they're all going
my friends are here watching my mom this
is not that bad
and after that I was Fearless I just
like having fun when I'm on stage
I get real happy up there like maybe
that's the only time in my adult life
that I feel like myself is standing up
there you know I mean like a gladiator
and the mics is on him and you look down
and it's just all these Smiles around
you and they get dressed they put
perfume on and stuff and they're going
to see your show that feels good man
these people you know they love you even
if it's for a minute they really do they
they love you man you know it's not good
I love fast yeah it's the best feeling
man I love standing you got to make life
interesting like that because
flimsy life is flimsy you think you're
gonna live with it but not gonna live
forever
it's dangerous out here we know what's
going on